I shaved my legs everyday it's seasonal  I do not shave my legs I don't know why  I shave my legs guess is just cuz that's  what people do if I think like so when I  like is going to see my legs then I'll  shave my legs and I think it does feel  better honestly I feel like I shaved  more from other women than for men  oh no that just doesn't sound worth it  my mother used to tell me that beauty is  pain no that doesn't sound right  no if there's a chance my flesh is going  to get eaten or have hairy legs I'll  just go with hairy legs I would be  scared if I had this in my bathroom that  I would like be tired and like put it on  my hair I think it makes sense that  women shave their legs because of  marketing women do a lot of things  because of marketing I think that's like  the world that we live in being aware of  it is important not the way I do it I am  going to efficient saver if lucious I  likes every day